and by the power of casual hate skull
decide to let you guys know that i can
sing so well
by the power of castle hate school i am
hella mark harley and boy oh
boy
do we have a boop boop
for you so i actually i'm going to start
off this episode with a little link that
i thought was
i didn't know where to categorize it so
i'm just like let's play it up top and
then i'm going to give you my little
lesson my 2022 cut recap so this guy in
january is 210 pounds february 190
uh march 184
he's now
come on video go april 178
and so we see you know pretty
significant differences between each one
it's noticeable now he's 175 of course
things are probably going to slow down a
little bit as you go on it's harder to
just keep up the exact same
pace of fat loss if you are fat to begin
with july he's 172 and so we're
approaching present time now uh i guess
that's the end of the video but
that's nearly 40 pounds
in the course of seven months
and
what i wanted to
[Music]
point out with this video is often
people
underestimate the degree
to which they need to lose weight in
order to look
a certain way
we've been sold this mean by the fitness
industry that that
certain parts of your body are just the
issue you're stubborn belly fat right
that doesn't seem to go away or
you know you're back fat or girls worry
about different places on their body
that are fat you know their love handles
their
hip dips and their inner thighs all
these different things
of course we carry fat slightly
differently from man to woman from
individual to individual but
like if you have a belly chances are
you're 30 pounds away from being ripped
ah
it's a tough truth but at least if you
accept that
you'll understand the the distance of
the journey that you have to go and i
don't think that's even particularly
more daunting i think the most daunting
part is really getting yourself going
and getting the fundamentals down and
that's why anybody who i talk to it's
like let me get you a basic
understanding of this notion of a
caloric deficit
and uh and building you know the basic
principles of a diet in relation to your
own
size
um because
without that
you're not gonna lose any weight and i
think you know for him probably getting
you know that first 10 pounds getting on
track getting
to a place where he was consistent
i think that
is a huge factor it's not like you you
lose 30 pounds you're like oh but i'm
running out of momentum or something or
you know that generates its own momentum
being in shape generates its own
momentum because the better shape you're
in the easier it is to do the same
workouts that you did before
the more that you work out the more
you're in a habit of working out and
this is part of your identity your
psychology your mood as we always talk
about mood stability um and mood
regulation for those of you who are
emotionally intelligent and not
emotionally tarted
banned blocked we're off youtube so this
is now on rumble um thank you for
joining us here on rumble
and the haters will say on rumble
podcast
with rumble mark harley so
this guy and i don't think he's that big
because he was pretty fat too like
at 210 pounds
so
by compare if i was that body fat
percentage i'd probably be like 280 or
290
at the height of six seven that i am now
this guy i'm assuming is five nine five
ten
210 pounds lost 40 pounds and and was
finally ripped
but just bite that bullet guys a lot of
you guys you know if you're coming to me
if you're coming to me obese uh and and
you want a six-pack right because
this is a generic thing to say i think
there's many other reasons
to motivate yourself to work out besides
just getting a six-pack but if that's
the vision you have in your head
you may need to recalibrate
your journey a little bit and understand
that like
you know
i have abs right now
to a degree but i'm still 20 pounds
overweight
like easily you know like i look back at
pictures of myself during the pandemic
when i was doing a lot of body weight
workouts a lot of running and stuff like
that i was 230 pounds and my body fat
percentage was
great to me like looking back i'm like
oh damn i really was ripped and uh you
know that can be a 20 pound difference
even though it might be like oh just a
little bit here and there we'll spread
that out over
my giant body and you got 20 pounds of
disgusting that uh so i just wanted to
point that out and
people tend to overrest or like
underestimate the amount of body fat
they need to lose they tend to
overestimate also the
the muscle that they need to put on in
order to look a certain way because once
you're down at a certain body fat
percentage like a pound of muscle
is visible noticeable and it makes a
huge difference so like
you know if you if your starting point
is like i want to lose 10 pounds of fat
and gain 10 pounds of muscle it's like
well
try losing 20 pounds of fat and gaining
5 pounds of muscle so double one and
half the other
and that'll be the mark harley math
portion of the podcast for the day
but that's just a rough like
idea of
the ballpark that people are usually in
and how wrong they are per usual all
right the next segment i'm actually
really excited about this stuff
the next segment on help i'm on peptides
it's not technically steroids here but
this is something that
i don't know if i've ever been more
excited to try a compound and that's
saying something because i've put a lot
of stuff in my body kid loves compounds
the kid loves
[Laughter]
put that on a t-shirt the kid loves
compounds and it's true you know it's
very true
so this
compound that i'm talking about today
oh and also it's a double entendre for
compound lifts right
look at that hey buddy
so the the picture is just me like doing
an overhead press with a needle in my
ass
they're both compounds guys get it
the back of the shirt is an explanation
of the joke
um so this stuff is called cerebral
license and this was first brought to my
attention
by the uh
extremely intelligent leo rex of leo and
longevity
again one of the best channels out there
for kind of like my
show i'd say it's like it's rooted in
fitness it's rooted in
certain things
like bodybuilding or gaining muscle but
it's a lot of branch-offs from there and
leo's is
in a similar sense you might get there
because oh he's talking about an
anabolic compound that i'm interested in
but then you'll go down the rabbit hole
of his channel and you know
be looking at his penis enlargement
videos who knows i don't know what you
might be interested in looking at i'm
just taking a guess okay
you little dick [ __ ] no um
but seriously his his videos on random
stuff like that on the you know in the
cholinergic system which is what
nicotine affects on the serotonin system
on the dopamine system just off the top
of my head all these different system
videos um
they're super informative and this is
one of the things that kind of overlaps
with these other like serotonin and
dopamine because it's general brain
function
um i'll read the description of what
cerebralizing is and then we'll get into
uh the one percent of his video that i
actually retained and can regurgitate
for you guys cerebral lysis is a mix of
enzymatically treated peptides derived
from pig brains now hold on a second
before you go a lot of things are taken
from pig brains all right it's okay to
eat them i think
it constitutes its constituents can
include neuropeptides that are similar
to fragments of natural nootropic
factors ntf for example uh ciliary or
yes ciliary nootrophic
uh
factor cntf brain derived neotropic
factor bdnf
glial cells derived neurotrophic
neutrophic factor
n g d n f which i knew any of what these
words mean nerve growth factor ngf and
insulin-like growth factor igf
cerebrolysis has been studied here's the
real important part it has been studied
for potential use in a wide variety of
neurodegenerative disorders it can be
beneficial in the treatment of dementia
including alzheimer's disease stroke and
traumatic brain injury ding ding ding
when i hear traumatic brain injury my
eyes light up
now the thing behind my eyes my brain
doesn't really light up because of the
traumatic brain injuries that i've had
but
hopefully after taking some cerebral
lysin that will change it so
my understanding
um and if you google cerebral eyes and
leo longevity
the title of the video is something like
changing my brain with um
like you know peptides or pig brains or
something like that uh you know a sort
of clickbait title but this stuff is
very
serious it
basically promotes
the growth of neurons in your brain
it reduces general inflammation
and
uh
it's
used in things like like somebody has a
stroke and they immediately give a high
dose of cerebral lysin and it seems to
be
neuroprotective
right um
if you have traumatic brain injuries and
leo's kind of like why isn't this stuff
given to mma fighters after a fight
because it can both protect your brain
and
actually lead to a growth of your brain
there's like he went he goes through a
variety of studies in both animals and
humans and makes sure to delineate those
two things because it doesn't always
overlap just because something happens
in a rat doesn't mean that it's going to
happen in a human
and there might be more limited capacity
for actually looking at you know humans
brain you can't just kill the people at
the end of the study and look inside
their brain you could but like you know
that's more of a nazi germany thing it's
like super frowned up you know like yeah
it's like you know can we just
we're competing with china and we still
can't
murder civilians and put them in a
museum um
you know as uh thanks biden as a must
thanks biden
um yeah that's uh that's a reference to
what's that think of bodies in motion
and it's all like chinese political
prisoners you know as the bodies
puts a little i'm glad i didn't know
that going into it but you find out
afterwards you're like oh that's pretty
dark huh
so
this stuff i'm actually about to order
it uh for myself so if you walk in on me
and i'm just doing math equations on the
chalkboard in the hallway of some
prestigious university don't get mad
that i'm the next matt damon
just say oh this cerebral license
finally kicking in dude look at that and
if you if i come in one day and it's
like whoa dude like this
like my hat is suddenly like way tighter
it's like oh because his brain's growing
um
it does apparently cause brain growth
and
i'm not gonna say
it increases your iq but i read certain
things like
it increases your working memory and
your ability to recall things well that
sort of like these elements of iq it can
potentially reduce anxiety and that's
what leo
was actually taking it for
and describes some debilitating social
anxiety amongst other things that the
cerebellicin seemingly cured because
some of these things like when you look
into you know what is the purpose of
ssris
part of it
that takes a while but you know is
uh ultimately what you're looking for is
neurogenesis it should make you create
uh new neurons
and that's apparently something that
cerebral lysin does very well and the
side effect profile is very safe so
that's most of what i want to say about
it because i want to look into it more
and kind of you know i'll guide you in
the right direction and go hey you want
to hear about all the studies and all
the ways in which um
it it shows a lot of promise
just for doing
like you'd have to you have to study in
really specific ways you know it's like
let's compare the motor function you
know after a month of use in between
stroke victims or something like that
you know
it has to be hyper-specific you can't
just be like does this make you smarter
or not or you know
that's a more difficult
you know test to implement i would
assume
but i'm interested to try it and even uh
vigorous steve had a
video that i just watched where he was
talking about taking cerebral lysin
just for central nervous system recovery
after strenuous workouts because i don't
know if you know this but like
when you have a strenuous workout like
let's say you do a crazy leg day
that affects your entire body and your
brain you know
are you gonna be at your sharpest after
you're doing 30 hard sets of legs
probably not you're going to be very
physically exhausted but also mentally
exhausted
and that's you know part of like over
training or feeling beat down when
you've done a lot of heavy days in a row
is this central nervous system which all
central nervous system fatigue which all
starts in your brain and
he said his central nervous system
fatigue or recovery
was enhanced tremendously with that so
another sort of anecdotal evidence point
that this stuff does have an effect on
your brain
i'm ordering it from cosmic nootropics
the dosing can be like two milliliters
to
if you're a stroke victim they set up to
like 60 you know so
five milliliters in a syringe is the
most that you can probably get online
and you can you know inject it
intramuscularly or intravenously i'm far
too much of a [ __ ] to enter
intravenously inject anything on my own
uh i'd have to hit up my local
phlebotomist for that
but
uh i will be trying it in the near
future and so just don't be surprised if
i come back with the receipts and it's
like oh
he's got a 3000 iq like sorry not i told
you you know but now i'm
now i bought all this cerebralizing
on planet earth
hey mark what's gotten into you today
well i'll tell you what's gotten into me
today some happy hippo kratom where do i
get that at
happyherbals.com i'm gonna use primo
promo code thick boy
even though i have it free at the office
here again i like to support the company
because
it's a great company and i believe in
supporting small businesses now
how do you feel on it well i feel warm i
feel happy
i feel like
i can support other people being happy
because my mood is taken care of
and that's really all i can ask for in a
substance in an all natural herbal
compound that has the purest ingredients
in a world where you can't always
guarantee that when it comes to kratom
but if you do go to happy herbals.com
use promo code thickboy you won't be
disappointed i guarantee it
you know a lot of people have been
asking me lately mark was that really an
oak and stone shirt that brendan wore on
the joe rogan fight companion reunion
show well yes it was okay and god damn
did he look good and god damn do i look
good right now in the same shirt just in
gray and oh
you can wear it to a special event you
can also just wear it podcasting with a
cool brand of bill's hat on and it's
just like casual mode like nobody looks
at me and goes he's overdressed they go
he's over sexy for sure but overdressed
no he's the perfect amount of dressed in
oak and stone clothing and if you go to
oakstoneclothing.com and use code hella
at checkout
guess what
you're going to get 10 off
and you're also going to be able to talk
to me afterwards and hey look i bought
this thing and i'll be like cool i'm
coming up with another promo right now
for the month of september
you know it's a big surprise like i have
it it's ready to go it's but i just i
can't tell you like yet because we're
waiting for the launch date and that i
just want everything to be perfect so
check back in with me um in three to
eight days
and you'll know what you're getting
bye
okay let's just talk about some subtle
items because
it's actually like i i sneak this in i
go like oh you don't even like i'm not
necessarily gonna say sup right at the
beginning of the conversation it might
be a little bit later but we'll still
get it in i went to a movie last night
called the blonde experiment
this is a multi-year journey
to friends of mine and a woman i went to
high school with veronica mannion who's
on insecure she plays kitty she's one of
the white workers at
the place where issa rey's character
had a job
and so you know she'll make a few
appearances every season very talented
actress very talented
singer songwriter she directed a movie
on a shoestring budget a few years ago
called boys boozer brownies which i was
also in and again just
making something
out of an extremely low budget very
impressive to me especially if you're in
the film industry and you know like what
it takes to get all these people
together
and
come out with something that even makes
sense you know telling a linear story is
difficult enough and she's been able to
uh with her co-writer and co-director on
this one her good friend uh ariel hart
has made a movie called the blonde
experiment which is a fun buddy comedy
about these girls who
decide to
dye their hair blonde
or really wear blonde wigs and to reap
the benefits of of being blonde but it's
very heightened very absurd
lots of music and physical comedy and
stuff like that they made this i look
back at the seed and spark it was 25 000
bucks that they raised
three years ago
and it's just now getting out to
theaters so that's another reminder to
people of like you know if you're trying
to make movies or do anything on this
scale it can be a long time and and uh
you know it's got to come from a place
of really really really wanting it
because people come up to me like i want
to make this movie and it's like
you know would you be willing to make it
for 25 000 bucks over the course of
three years
maybe so
but it has to be a labor of love like
that that you're willing to see all the
way through because
25 g's is not a lot of money and so
you've got to be calling in all the
favors anyway went to the screening last
night thought it was fantastic
the whole audience was laughing and
that's just special because
again you're you're competing we're used
to seeing movies that
at minimum you know we'll consider a
small indie film something that was made
for five million dollars you know so
this was made for like
a day you know the budget of one day of
shooting for one of the stars of a
movie that's uh you know mid-range five
to ten million dollar picture
it's
but
the principle here that i really want to
get at is
creativity
especially in storytelling
goes such a long way
so if you have a really good story
and you have humor
that will be 90 of the thing and even
just drawing the best talent and drawing
you know the best actors the best
directors best editors and people who
will also invest into this it all starts
there
so write a better script how about that
huh
also it went to joshua tree
get over it dude like you're like people
are like oh my god
joshua tree again this is the second
time in three years
um did i do some mdma yes i did all
right
and
my takeaway from that is the hangover is
too bad to do it all the time it's very
fun while you're doing it in a pathogen
i think the things that you say are both
like
i have access to the memories of my
thoughts and feelings while i'm on mdma
and i feel like that is
the nature of healing
and this compound
used as a therapeutic is the fact that
you can remember these things you're not
just like
getting drunk and destroying your memory
what happened last night i was so
lovey-dovey and like i mean you're my
best friend but then i forgot in the
morning
you're
actually able to recall
your perspective with heightened
empathy and love right this is the drug
of love but
to me what that means is just
being more open and empathic which
allows you to see things from other
people's perspectives so you can have
discussions and work on things
like work through issues it's not just
something for fun you can think about
problems that you have that are
interpersonal you can think about past
trauma
you can turn this into a therapy session
if you want doesn't that sound fun
do drugs so you can do a therapy session
on yourself
sounds like a fantastic saturday night
but it's true and i'm not encouraging
you to do that but what i'm saying is i
see i see where people are coming from
using this as a legitimate uh
therapeutic
device
because
you might be able to make some progress
you know you don't just wake up like
whoa what happened
i licked your booty hole all night
that's crazy
where's the video i also want an
electric bike ride uh people you know
how we see people giving shop [ __ ] for
getting on the electric bike like on
these huge bike rides turns out it's not
as easy as you would think right even in
the highest gear it provides some
assistance but like you're still
pedaling have you ever done an e-bike no
yeah it's like
i thought the e was for easy but it's
not
it's for like eh
could be more powerful um no we still we
got i don't know how far we went we went
deep into the uh
the mountains and
you know could have gone a longer route
but we'll save that for another day yada
yada so whatever it was i was like oh
this is it it surpassed my expectations
as far as difficulty because you can
make it as difficult as you want right
you can have it be a regular bike or you
can have a little assistance or a little
more right there's three different
levels there's levels to the e-bike game
is what i'm saying
and did we see any rattlesnakes no and
so i'm starting to wonder is brendan
just making this [ __ ] up you know he's
always like oh i saw a rattlesnake i'm
like it's funny that only you've seen
rattlesnakes
like uh you know they remember one time
you brought in that place like oh i
caught one and we're like
that's a plastic snake yeah that you put
a baby rattle on the back of you're not
fooling anybody those are gummy worms
those he brought a pack of gummy worms
in oh my goodness you know
i wanted to hit y'all
with an unconventional back workout for
this week's brother science academy last
week i did the yeah
thank you without the applause i wasn't
going to do the segment if there's one
thing that grinds my gears it's a
[ __ ] conventional background
[Laughter]
walk into the gym you see people doing
lat pulldowns
or you just throw a fit you know
um
smash your fists through the uh display
case at the 24-hour fitness
check-in kiosk
look that's a really specific vision
that i'm having of the glass there and
what i would do okay maybe it's
different at your gym i don't know but
[ __ ] something up so
go through it real quick unconventional
back workout weighted body weight rows
wait is it body weight is it extra rate
what's going on here i'm talking about
you're on a smith machine or any sort of
barbell setup that's close enough to the
ground where your back is almost
touching when your arms are fully
extended like this and your feet are
ideally up on something that your feet
are extended right and they're up on a
bench
ideally around the same level that
you're grabbing
uh
the bar at maybe a little bit lower but
then you know that first of all that's a
great exercise in and of itself
especially because i think movements
like that promote you to use good form
you can't swing you can't use momentum
and
i'm typically motivated to like try to
get that extra few inches of squeezing
at the end of the movement more so
than other back movements or the rowing
movements now what if you add a plate to
your chest or something like that
fantastic right and it's not that hard
or put it on your stomach or your pelvis
or wherever you need to do that to
overload this movement and it kind of
almost guarantees you
good form because your upper body has to
be
uh you know a plank in order to pull
this off and you'll know
if your body's moving out of that
position and your hips are bending or
whatever so as long as you can keep a
plank you're probably doing good form
also
rack pull-ups have we talked about that
before this is a
movement that is part of dc training
that dante trudeau came up with but it's
basically
imagine you're on that same smith
machine or barbell setup you know you're
in a cage of some sort
you want a
you want to grab the bar in a wide grip
pull up
uh
grip
that
you know so you're looking like this
you're outstretched you don't want to be
straight up and down you're outstretched
you want to have a stretch on your lats
and your carries at the top of the
movement or sorry the bottom of the
movement your butt wants to be off the
ground maybe touching or like just
hovering above
your back
wants to come straight down so i'm
sitting here my back straight up and
down
i'm bent at the hips once again my feet
are coming up
to rest
on a bench or something that elevates
them
uh
higher than your hips right so you want
to be making like
a little you know tilted v shape but
your back straight up and down
do a pull up like that what you'll
notice is it keeps your back perfectly
straight up and down and makes
uh you know the last few inches of that
movement again very difficult because
you can't like pull back you know you
can't arc your back to get up you have
to just keep pulling straight up and
down then what you want to do is add
weight to your lap you can do that
with a plate with a dumbbell uh
a lot of people prefer those fixed
barbells because you can balance it you
know just the bar in your lap
you start adding weight like that and
you'll see you don't need a whole lot to
make it the equivalent of a very heavy
lat pull down except you're sort of
guaranteeing this good form i like it
better just because it creates a more
straight up and down movement if that's
what you're going for in a vertical pull
the next one we're going to do is rack
deadlifts everything is just racked up
today
rack deadlifts are basically anything
that's like slightly below the knee
or even right above the knee or at the
knee it's a deadlift in a cage you're
going to be able to do more weight
now when you take that beginning
position
out of the movement
that hip hinge when you reduce that what
you are doing is building uh your spinal
erectors building your trapezius and
you're also building your lats
when you're just holding on now i would
use straps for this obviously because
it's often going to be
much more than you can do deadlift reps
at
when you're just moving a weight and
your whole body is struggling just to
not let your arms rip out of their
sockets that's going to build your traps
right all that stretch downward like
this you don't need to shrug it
you're going to get the trap work uh
you're going to get the lat work you're
going to get the spinal director move
and it does have carry over in my
opinion two deadlifts right not perfect
you can't just do rack deadlifts but
you'll be able to handle more weight
it's a great central nervous system
uh stressor
and you will grow from it you know this
is one of my favorite overall
back lifts a lot of people poo poo
right because they just think you're
cheating at a deadlift but it's a
different movement and then finally i
even tried this myself but i saw
somebody do it and i was like i need
that in my life it's a rear delt behind
the back barbell raise so imagine you're
bent over at the waist or you take a
barbell really
you have it behind your back you're
standing then you bend over
at the waist and lift it up and back can
you kind of imagine what's that what
that's doing you're getting this really
hard contraction
in uh a not very strong position for
your rear delts
but it works right
and so i'll be trying that i'll be
filming it and i'll be allowing you guys
to laugh at me when i inevitably fail
now
we're introducing a new segment okay
it's the patrice o'neill portion of the
podcast do you mind starting this video
at 209 i thought this is
ready
uh yes
but it's either
she's happy or i'm happy with the
possibility of her being happy are you
hearing life and happiness is
paramount because let me tell you why a
man's happiness is very very simple it's
based on
uh it's not based on intellectual [ __ ]
it's not based on some metaphysical [ __ ]
is based on gut happiness we can waste
time and be happy we can daydream and be
happy now when we're happy and we have
an abundance of it it trickles down to a
more complicated needy creature who
needs [ __ ]
who could he be referring to
in compliance and i have to be in tune
with your your soul to know what is
going to make you happy now how does it
be in tune to your soul
you know
this youtube algorithm you start
watching one thing and then it
recommends you more and more and more
and there's there's a channel or
probably a few channels that just upload
these amazing
clips of patrice o'neill talking on the
opening anthony show
and
i knew patrice o'neil was a genius
before this and like he's widely
considered a comedic genius but
his ability to philosophize on male
female relationships
is actually quite incredible and i find
myself agreeing with many of the things
he said even though they can come off as
harsh because what he's saying right now
is basically like it doesn't matter if
your woman's happy like
don't prioritize that over your
happiness and the the beat before that
he was talking about look my girl wants
to move it with me i'm not going to let
her because she's she's got her own
place i don't want her to be there on
her period or whatever and i don't know
if that's like a mood thing or you know
a different reasoning for that but
like it comes off as harsh and the woman
in the situation who's in on the show
with them is protesting to that um
but you just can't come at patrice
o'neill and have some weak ass argument
he just knows how to destroy everyone's
counterpoints and in this case the point
that he's making is
if you put a woman's happiness over your
happiness
sure she might be happy but you're
definitely not going to be happy and if
you prioritize your own happiness you
can be happy and there is a better
chance that she's going to be happy as a
result there's still no guarantee
because as he's saying
men's happiness is far more simple
and i kind of believe that you know i
just feel like i know the things that
make me happy and they are very simple
and it often just comes down to like
am i moving every day am i doing things
every day am i like in enough contact
with people that i'm close with every
day it's
you know am i getting food every day
and we all know that women can be more
complicated than that but it's also just
this general life lesson
of prioritizing your happiness
over other things because everything
else you do
is predicated uh on your happiness as a
man
happiness and what that is is a
different discussion but i would just
say your mental well-being your mental
health you don't need to be like
exuberant and happy and overjoyed but
you need to be
feeling your best to a degree you need
to be thinking clearly you need to be at
least not like negative and resentful
because nothing comes from that and you
can't
provide for other people effectively
when you feel a sense of scarcity and i
notice that with other people too like
when other people feel threatened you
can't be generous you know and that's
part of this like molly conversation
it changes your emotional landscape to a
degree that you feel safe like giving
and
cooperating and negotiating and
you know meeting somebody halfway i
guess would be another way to put it
being vulnerable
if you're under attack it's very hard to
be vulnerable i always say this about
you know people coming to my page and
hate it's like
you're not funny and i would acknowledge
it if it was a really good joke or you
know you're roasting me in an original
or funny way but you're angry and that
affects your ability to be creative and
to be light-hearted and
like come up with a joke outside of
something that really signals your
resentment
that's an analogy to this situation
where if you're a guy and you realize
like
i'm with somebody whether it's a woman
whether it's a male friend whether it's
a parent whether it's anybody in your
life
who's taking disproportionately and they
don't care about your well-being
you're never going to feel great because
nobody including yourself is looking out
for you
and it's an argument for selfishness to
a degree just that you cover your basics
because that makes you a better person
especially as a man when you're expected
to
provide and give certain things to other
people you're going to be performing
your best
and in a position to give others what
they need if you look out for yourself
and don't let anybody
convince you otherwise you know and
that's something that i struggle with
too because i've you know been told many
times in my life that i'm selfish just
because like
you know i'll get somebody pregnant and
they have a kid and i go out for
cigarettes and 10 years later they're
calling me like whatever happened and
i'm like dude like i have to look out
for me so
no but i have been called selfish many
times in my life
by manipulative people now i've had
people will call you selfish and it
could be legitimate but i'm talking
about
oh when i don't do something that you
want me to do suddenly i'm selfish but
that still plays in your brain like
anything where it's like wait am i you
know and you're sitting there like i've
heard it before heard it both ways right
am i selfish and a terrible person or am
i a good person
well you know
you're going to be a worse person if you
allow people to tell you that you're a
bad person for not
being 100 selfless and cow towing to
their demands okay can we just is that a
good enough thing for the first one
oh my god
are we
are we already
good thing i have 30 this is why we
can't have nice gyms
how you know it's time to switch gyms
and what this guy's doing
is
like
a lat pull down into a tricep extension
i've never related so much to a video in
my life
because when i see this and i used to
see this all the time for example like
la fitness in hollywood uh it comes to
mind i would work out there and i'd see
these dudes in the morning who like
i'm not gonna say they were like didn't
have any muscle but it's like it's
you're not looking at a guy with with an
enviable physique and
they put the whole stack on the the
tricep you know machinery a cable stack
with the the apparent intention of doing
a tricep movement
but instead of just having the weight
and actually doing it properly they're
starting off with a pull down and using
all of them and i get like okay a little
momentum at the start which should still
be sort of improper but like i'm talking
about like you're lowering it for three
feet before you get to the triceps
and again i just look at these people
and go what went wrong in childbirth
that you're now adding this lat pull
down to your tricep extension
i don't know you know
can we get you some cerebral lysin call
back i mean we're talking about
nootropics here um
it makes me
want to leave this earth frankly
but it's like no it's like nobody ever
told you nobody in this gym is gonna i'm
not gonna tell you because i know people
don't want to hear that but like how did
you make it through life to this point
where you think that's working your
triceps
you're wrong
you're just wrong the fitness community
body that's more of you'd be
like uh shredded this guy's like three
percent buying one of these charts right
shredded is like three percent body fat
lean is like six percent body fat
fat is like
ten percent body fat
obese is like 15 percent morbidly obese
like you know 18 19 and dead is anything
over 20. i'm ascribing these numbers
it's just like you know dead is like a
normal guy who looks like he has
um
you know a little weight to lose around
his midsection he's he's having trouble
targeting that stubborn belly fat but
it's true and you know what i don't mind
that either because
i tell people like people you know
you're gonna get fat when you get older
i'm like no i'll kill myself
just kidding but i would if i couldn't
if you told me oh you can't lose weight
i'm like well i gotta leave this earth
then somehow
this guy's hilarious skyler's uh
scotch i think his name is
it might be in there you don't need to
train legs if you're swimming no legs
this guy does a lot of good leg day
humor um about how like you can't grow
your upper body and your lower body at
the same time yada yada but like it's
funny because it's it's accurate i feel
like guys do actually have leg day
phobia um and i'm trying to correct that
with the five day a week leg day
protocol
that i'm the only person to ever think
of only one oh yeah me entering work
after realizing i'm the only one who
lives and therefore not legally
obligated to listen to anyone it's true
you're not
um it's ace ventura walking into the
office with that
it is kind of true though i
i and i'm not saying that this is a bad
thing i feel like this is part of
this self-esteem and self-confidence
like
when you lift
you kind of feel better about yourself
and maybe you look at other people who
don't work out at all and you go like i
remember even if you're not going i'm
inherently better than you because i
work out there is an element to which i
look at people who don't do any sort of
exercise and i feel bad for them
because
i know they're not as happy as they
could be i know their
sense of
well-being just on a mental level but
also
those
tricky elements of like your
self-perception and your self-esteem how
you feel about yourself which of course
can change
moment to moment for many people um but
exercise is one of those things that
helps keep that consistent for me
and uh so yeah i feel better when i work
out and i look at other people and go oh
my sucked to be you fatty
this this guy gets doubted anita propose
and then gets a
cramp in his hamstring
ah so funny cause what are you gonna do
luckily he's got like his team over here
is this at the like what is going on
uh because these guys come in like a
damn pit crew
you know they're just like
get that hamstring all ironed out but
what a hilarious moment and uh extremely
memorable too he's down on a knee and
then also just goes down to his face
like
well that's a good strategy if you're
like
going for the proposal and then you're
like last second you're like mom this is
a bad decision
casey with the ultimate bachelor
perspective
you know i've thought about like how
would i get out of doing a proposal like
should i be in love with somebody you
want to marry them but then like at the
last second change my mind until that
rings on you can still get the hell out
of there you're like fake assassination
attempt
with the simplest one it's just oh and
then you just like roll off like on the
side
oh man i gotta get to a doctor but i
can't stand
her dad so what do you do me at the end
of the dinner table and it's
jay cutler i believe uh yeah it's jay uh
posing just looking gigantic and look i
have no shame in that if you ask me what
i do it's like isn't it obvious
i'm jacked
i'm professionally buff
when the spot when the spotter grabs the
bar too early this cracked me up
no no no no no no no no no no no no
but it do be like that um thanks biden
and i always yeah thanks bride thanks
for having me you biden ruined my pr can
you believe this true story uh anytime
somebody just gets near it you're like
you know you're also like benching so
you're like
your face is all tight and you're like
communication is key
pov
what lifters think it's gonna happen
when they start to search workout videos
um in the studio
that's so embarrassing
it's so embarrassing bro hey come over
here look at him
whoa dude oh my god
dude he got kicked out of the gym for
watching uh how-to workout videos and
this is something that resonated with me
because i feel like
so many things can be solved by
like you don't know how to dead lift go
look it up there's so many good videos
online about how to perform these basic
uh fundamental lifts
so i want to help you if you come to me
and you're like how do you do a lift
i can tell you because i'm an amazing
coach but also i'm an amazing youtube
guide so i'm going to tell you go into
youtube type in the lift that you just
typed out to me because you have a hand
computer at your disposal
and then you're going to figure it out
and then come to me if you have any
questions but you know don't be
embarrassed to look things up because
i'm obviously the most advanced lifter
in california and i'm still looking up
how-to videos so does that make me gay
maybe
but
i can live with that when you get caught
deadlifting at planet fitness and it's
don't call steve austin getting kicked
out of the arena create some audio then
[Music]
mcmahon is the gym manager
and he's like i did it and i'll do it
again
it do be like that though
[Music]
just one of those funny things where
it's like you know
deadlifting is the most basic exercise
of all time but if you walk into a plan
of fitness or another gym that doesn't
promote this
you know that that has it in their head
in their trainer's head this is a bad
thing to do it's like the worst thing
that you could ever do it's like how
dare you you cannot deadlift and drop a
weight
there's techno music playing on the
loudspeakers but you are making too much
noise
another classic
hair fail
hair bale fail that's what i typed it
and
what is going on here i don't know but
this is just a recommendation to
everybody out there if you have long
luxurious hair put it all the way up
um or cut it off but
you know could have been a lot worse
she could have broken her neck
so this is really just a happy story of
how this woman survived a traumatic
injury at the hands of a squat rack
today
this
this video says i don't know i always
kind of distrust these you know videos
that win in post these guys didn't
believe
i could lift the same as them now we see
guys in the video we see like guys who
kind of like look a little bit skeptical
but like i'd want to see proof they're
like no we're you're so weak because you
look at this girl you're like dude she's
got
a dunk-a-donk
she's not super thick but you can tell
she works out and then what is she
lifting i wish i could tell is that two
45s and a
35 it says 5kg on the inside plate okay
yeah in the inside and then there's what
a two other team
are those blueys
are those i wish we knew because that
would make that would make me
have a better
guess on whether these guys think she
could you know is it 400 pounds it's not
400 pounds but the most it could be
would be
295 like 315 i would say probably the
most
but
even that she's capable of doing it you
know
it's strong for her but i just wish men
would be not so judgmental oh you know i
saw another funny thing
that'll just bring up because it's
another like
we jump on now sometimes women are right
and sometimes this video totally could
be true but
there is this video going around of like
an anchor fire because she chose to let
her hair go gray you know and i'm like
you know obviously like i'm relating to
that as somebody who's constantly
discriminated about my gray hair um
i'm always threatened to be fired from
my job here thick boy
purely based on my hair they're like
mark your performance is perfect but we
just the gray hand like this is a young
office could you could young it up could
you brown it up a little bit
and
so i'm automatically my heart strings
are tugged by any suggestion that
somebody would be discriminated against
for having uh hair the color of seagull
[ __ ] now
if you look at the story though
she
the guy who fired the owner of the
company's like no no that's not true
like there was no discussion of her just
going gray
um
it was coincidental like she goes gray
and then at some point after that she
was fired
but
everybody's jumping to her side like you
know like l'oreal i was like
hold this beautiful you know whatever
these uh people jump on these things
automatically and
just want to ride this bandwagon of like
a woman in peril oh no she's being
discriminated against you're like was
she that like what are you sure she
wasn't now
it's like saying like a woman didn't get
a role as a teenager because she's 50
like she's being discriminated against
because of her clothing or you know it's
like
it's
in the field of entertainment
yes sometimes you can be too old for a
job and that's a valid
unfortunately
a reason to replace somebody you know
you've aged out of the position uh
like i did last year on my disney shows
like mark we just don't buy you as a
teenager anymore
so it's a real thing that happens people
jump to the side of this person and i
just love i the last thing in the video
that was said was
uh
the company that she worked for this
news station
is
hiring like an independent investigator
to look into it so it's like oh [ __ ]
i kind of hope that it all comes out
that it was like no no she was actually
you know super difficult to work with
and nobody liked her at the station
whatever it's like oh that was it but we
spent two years saying it was because
she has gray hair
that would be delightful
but i hope they uh resolve this
peacefully i do not skip leg day this
man's going up
to this
what would you call that a
the thing that you put trash in that
goes on a truck normally like
it's a giant trash can right but you'd
normally load that up in a truck
incredible vocabulary lessons here on on
the haters will say this guy but he goes
at his back and uses it like a leg press
impressive
because i'm really going like you walked
by this and you thought i'm gonna lay in
my back and leg press it you know that
would be the last thing on my mind
passing something like that but you
gotta and even the range of motion is
pretty good
albeit he has a giant belly so his knees
touching his stomach is not that
impressive but you know more range of
motion there than a lot of people that i
see at 24 fitness on the leg press not
going to name any ms
uh is that it
is that all the things because guess
what crushed it nailed it and if you see
a headline about me getting fired from
thick boy studios
it's because of my gray hair and we all
need to stand together and rise up and
support me being old as [ __ ]